welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and we are back with
another installment
of the 15 minutes with a mental series
where we're
having a chat with some of the mentors
inside the recruitment mentors community
and we are asking them seven questions
in 15
minutes really excited to be uh joined
by james today
but before we get started james if you
could introduce yourself and let people
know
um who you are and then we'll get into
it
absolutely thanks for having me um yeah
i'm james mitra the founder of jbm
we're an exec search and recruitment
business that has been around for the
last eight years
um and we basically work with high
growth
tech scale ups recruiting ops strategy
and growth roles
and we also have a podcast called 40
minute mentor which is all about
inspiring career stories and mentorship
from amazing leaders and entrepreneurs
amazing thank you so i want to know from
you james what was
your biggest challenge in 2020 how did
you overcome it and what did you learn
from it
oh wow i think like everyone dealing
with a pandemic is probably the the
number one thing
i think probably there's two two main
challenges that that came up from that
though
one like everyone else adapting to
remote working
how do we keep that culture how do we
keep the team motivated
how do we hire new talent um and
probably what i'd say from that is that
that
first and foremost we over communicated
as a leadership team i think that's just
just making sure you know people that
you're present as a leader and that
kind of really landed well with the team
um i think we also
did our best just to acknowledge that it
was pretty crap and um
just make sure the team were okay to be
you know
be themselves and when they did feel
like they're having a bad day to be open
and honest about it
um and then we did like everyone else we
tried to to mix things up to make sure
that we had time for
you know over the you know non-work chat
so we put time in the diary each week
for
just basically like a coffee in a chit
chat no work allowed
talking about netflix or whatever and
just having little touch points little
little surprises so we'd send little
things through the post occasionally
just to kind of lift spirits
um but like everyone else it's been it's
been challenging um
you know some days and weeks have been
better than others we've done our best
to keep everyone going but i think it's
just a general acceptance that
this is not this is not normal um and we
just got to make the best of it as
possible
um and just be a really supportive sort
of leadership team to the business
i'd probably say the second thing for me
um
was around pipeline i think you know we
as soon as lockdown hit the first the
first one
our pipeline dropped off a cliff we
didn't do a lot of exact search work and
these are kind of big big potential fees
and big roles
and i think the the way we tackled it
was was firstly not
panic it's very easy to uh but we've
been around for a few years now
i think we were like how can we add
value you know how can we add value to
our candidates you know so we started
running
cv clinics we were doing shout outs on
linkedin for those that lost their jobs
we made sure we were there for our
clients so just just not hard selling at
all just being there like
finding out how they're doing regular
check-ins just trying to support as best
as we can
and when it was quiet i think what we
did was we used the time effectively
um so we we used that first lockdown to
launch a whole new service offering
called
sos which is effectively an on-demand
interim solution for startups
and frankly we didn't have enough work
at the time to be
you know we just we had time effectively
to work on something new
um and that's that's gone on to become a
really cool part of our business
so so effectively what's the learning
from that well
one it's to play the long game i think
it's uh you know
it's doing the basics right it's being
consultative it's not always hard
selling
and what we found is that now things are
sort of as things started to turn a
corner
clients remembered us candidates
remembered how we were in the beginning
of that lockdown how we
you know the sort of service that we
gave them and now things are turning
around and people are hiring again
our phone hasn't really stopped ringing
so we've been really really lucky
um amazing and yeah and i think those
tough times can bring out the best in
you in terms of creativity
um you know and trying new things and
that's why i'd always say to anyone
listening just
sometimes you just got to back your
skills and you've got to try new things
and sometimes it won't work but you'll
probably have fun you'll probably learn
a lot in the process
and that's that's effectively what we've
done with sos um yeah
it's been a really good experience
absolutely lovely thank you for
for sharing so i'd love to sort of hear
from you what working from home tip
could you share with other recruiters
listening to this that you feel has had
a sort of real positive impact on your
own productivity
oh um for me personally it's not i
i'm not the best at this if i'm honest
it's been i've been one of those people
that has uh has worked
pretty pretty long hours and and i
wouldn't encourage that um
but but i think the best thing that i've
done
is is go out for a walk every day um
break up the day at lunchtime i get out
i spend
half an hour i have lunch i have with
with the family and my wife and daughter
and
we go for a walk and i find that i get
my best ideas
and when i'm i'm walking around just in
the fresh air away from the screen
so i think that breaking up the day and
i've started taking more calls just
out and about and just trying to mix it
up a bit
so for me just it's so easy to get stuck
in in one place just like be on the
computer from dusteldorn
and but i really think the best work we
can do is when we're actually
get away from that that situation and
and give yourself a bit of time for
inspiration to think things through and
reflect and
that's that's kind of how i've tried to
do it and it's kept me a bit fresher
interesting so i know you touched on it
in the first question but what
what's been the most effective way for
for you guys then to win business in the
last 12 months
well to be honest with you i think
there's probably two things
one is is turning candidates into
clients um jbm
we've always pride ourselves on being
different and you know
investing a lot of time in building
relationships and as a result we've
grown through word of mouth primarily
and
and that's really come to the forum
lockdown because i think you can
sometimes see the worst of our industry
in times of
when times are challenging people get a
bit desperate they they sell harder
they they can be a little bit maybe
underhand
um i don't know you hear stories right
but actually i think the majority of our
industry
you know are really really conscientious
and really care about their clients and
candidates and i think that's the
that's when you can really make a
difference and stand yourself apart from
the competition
so for us it's been about developing
those relationships nurturing
them you know being as credible and and
useful as possible
and what we found is that that has as
times have changed
and as people have started to pick up
hiring again you know we've been able to
reach out to candidates who have moved
into jobs
and they've then given us opportunities
and i think that's that's that's for me
is like always going to be our number
one
um whether it's them putting a word into
their boss or whether it's them becoming
a hiring manager
so i think first and foremost candidates
turning candidates into clients
and then the second one is our podcast
um you know we've had more time
to create more content and do more
episodes of it
and actually it's been an amazing and i
recorded something for
for for you guys around this actually
it's an incredible
opportunity to build networks with
senior leaders
to spend quality time understanding them
and their business and their challenges
and then over the course of time you can
flip that relationship into a client
relationship and that's what we've done
quite effectively and it's been a
it's been a it's been a game changer
amazing
so what habit or hobby james did you
start in 2020 that you're going to
continue in 2021
oh is this outside of work or work
related
yeah anything that comes up for you
doesn't have to be about related
um oh well to be honest with you it
sounds sounds sad but it's press-ups i'm
okay i
hate yeah i i i've never really liked
i'm not really i used to put a lot of
sport i'm now a
dad of a five-year-old and i don't get
out enough um and one thing that i found
quite into is just like just doing
press-ups like breaking up the day with
a bit of press-ups it's like a
little bit of strength work it makes up
but the competitive recruiter in me is
always there so
every time i do something i want to try
and do a bit more the next day and you
get to a point where you're
you're racking up some half decent
numbers so for me it's just a good thing
you can do it anywhere
it keeps you sort of fit and strong and
you can add a little bit of competition
to it
nice so probably the most important
question
what do you think is better the first
coffee in the morning or the first pint
post work on a friday it's gotta be the
point
hasn't it i'm the coffee guy
but yeah the point's been uh
it's been needed but no i'm i love
coffee
i i start every day with the coffee um
and
i'll i'll say the pd aunts i'll go
coffee but
in this climate i'll i'll take both to
honestly yeah
fair right so the next questions it's
slightly different it's a scenario and i
just want to sort
how you would approach this scenario so
um i want to sort of the scenario is a
particular business that you've had on
your target client list
for over a year long period of time and
during that period there's been several
touch points with them you may have
um they may have engaged with your
content on linkedin
they may have even listened to your
podcast you may have sent them an email
um but through your candidate network
like you just been mentioning you
managed to get the sort of hiring
managers contact details
and you call them they pick up say hello
who is this and
just want to sort of hear how you would
approach that scenario
okay well well firstly i always quite
quickly tried to drop in some
sort of credibility bombs if i can um
yeah referencing people we know
in common things we have in common you
know past clients we've worked with that
are relevant to their industry
just something that instantly makes them
feel at ease that we know what we're
talking about
but actually for me particularly with my
business jbm
it's actually about storytelling um
these guys won't have a lot of time
they probably get called all the time
and and i quickly
want to try and get into why jbm is
different and a lot of that comes down
to
values and approach and that sort of
stuff so so for me i always talk about
quickly getting into the story of jbm
why
why i founded the business which was was
really to try and be the antithesis of
that transactional recruiter that
you know a lot of clients find annoying
um
and talk about how we grew through word
of mouth and um
you know i have really stuck true to
those values and i try and give some
specific examples again if i can if i
can tailor that towards
you know similar clients to theirs and
people that we've placed and things like
that i just try and get their
attention and what we've always found is
that people like the story
um and it's how you tell it and it's
obviously you can craft it in a way that
is more relevant to different audiences
but actually that
that it turns into more of a
conversation and a more discussion and
and often i'll ask them you know their
experiences of working with
recruiters and what hasn't been so good
and try and use that to create a
dialogue
um so that's that's typically how i'd
approach it um but yeah i think trying
to find common
common ground and and some credibility
that they would
kind of give you more time a day and
then the storytelling element i think is
something that sometimes overlooked
yeah i like it so final question then is
i sort of want you
to sort of imagine that you're you're
speaking to a recruiter that's listening
to this who has
set their goals for 2021 they've written
them down feeling motivated completely
convinced they can have a better year
than they did in 2020.
um i just want to hear like what your
advice would be to
recruiters listening to this that you
think would give them the best possible
chance of actually achieving
the goals they've set this year
it's a great question um so first and
foremost that we have a podcast called
40 minute mentor
um i know mentorship is something that
you're a big fan of and i think
mentorship
is so critical so if you're all set and
good to go one thing i would say is just
get a mentor join your community um
talk to people who've walked in your
shoes or or in the place that you want
to be
um that's not that you have to follow
everything they say but just like
so i think it's great to always be
talking to people that you respect
kind of learning from their experience
kind of adapting that to your
your plans and your experience too so i
think first of all is having that
sounding board
in whatever form that comes i think is
really important to keep you honest
um and then ultimately for me it's about
getting out there you know if you if
you're all set
you're motivated you're good to go i
think what you've got to do is back your
skills
sometimes you have to be patient and
bide your time but if you're doing the
basics right
if you're working hard if you're working
smart if you're
investing in your personal brand you're
building a reputation as a credible
recruiter that knows this stuff
and i think more often than not you will
hit your targets and i think that's
where
having the right mentorship alongside
that to support you when the
challenges come in and you you're facing
stuff that you're not you're not sure
how to contend with
and that's where that sort of thing
helps and i think being self-reflective
is is
and having that kind of learning
mindset's also really important so when
you're
each process you run each time you make
a placement each time you get a drop
out what can you take from that
experience what can you do different
next time
and so so having that kind of consistent
loop of
of learning i think is really important
um and and
like for me personally it's about you
know the the nuts and bolts for me is
investing in building relationships like
deep meaningful
relationships with everyone you work
with invest that time think longer term
you know really and i promise like if
you if you go above and beyond for your
candidates
then they will become clients they will
become advocates for you in the market
they will
they will you know they will help you
grow your personal brand
um you know and i think if you're if
you're a decent recruiter you know what
you're doing
you should then kind of take that
forward and hit you or hit your targets
love that no some great advice in there
james that was 15 minutes of a mentor
thank you wow that was fast absolute
pleasure thank you
thanks for having me and uh yeah um yeah
wishing you
continued success in 2021 i love what
you're doing
awesome